well good afternoon everyone we have a
real treat for you I am delighted first
of all to welcome you to today's science
technology and policy forum lecture as
I'm sure most of you know this series
started last fall and idea was to spark
dynamic campus-wide dialogue on
scientific and technological innovations
and their potential impact societal
impact as well as policy impact in fact
with our distinguished visitor today we
were talking about this that CMU in
sunlight is very unique in the way we
intertwine science technology
engineering with policy with business
the arts and humanities
as is the case today through this forum
CMU has welcomed and recognized thought
leaders to campus who expose us our
faculty our students and staff alike to
the ways in which research extends
beyond our classrooms and beyond our
labs excuse me
today I'm very pleased to introduce
Susan Athey as our distinguished speaker
Susan is the economics of Technology
professor at Stanford Graduate School of
Business where she focuses on many
things
in fact she's giving three lectures
during her visit to our campus three
lectures on very diverse topics her
research focuses on the economics of an
Internet marketplace design auction
theory and the intersection of computer
science machine learning economics she
has made many fundamental and
groundbreaking contribution to economics
and her research is distinguished both
in its application as well as its death
spanning industrial organization and to
the analysis of real-time data to
virtual currency her advice to business
and government around the world has
shaped global approaches to internet
research to internet search assets a
online policy news media which she will
diss
later on this morning this afternoon for
these and many other contributions she
has received a number of awards and
honors too many to enumerate she's a
member of both the National Academy of
Sciences and the National Academy of
Arts and Sciences and in 2007 she
received the John Bates Clark medal from
the American Economic Association which
honors exceptional American economists
under the age of 40 and is regarded as
the most prestigious award in economics
I should add that she is she was the
first woman to win this award I think
before you hear from Susan I want to
also say that I'm going to invite later
on Krishnan to come up at the end and
and help us with the closing remarks but
I also want to take a moment to thank
our Dean Krishnan as well as all college
of Hinds College for coordinating
Susan's event hosting her and also
putting her through at least three
presentations for the rest of her stay
here with that it is my pleasure to
invite Susan Athey to the podium to
speak about the impact of the internet
on the news media please join me in
extending a warm welcome to our guest
speaker to that
hi thanks everyone for coming and thank
you so much for inviting me here this is
just really an amazing place for someone
like me to visit where I'm often
speaking either to computer scientists
or to economists or to statisticians
separately and this is a really unique
place where so many people come together
and share my passion for the
intersection of all of these areas so
tonight I want to talk about the
Internet and the news media and you know
I got inspired about this work when I
was working on internet search I spent a
number of years working very closely
with Microsoft on their search engine on
their online advertising platform and
trying to understand really the the role
of the intermediary in how people get
information and how advertisers find
their consumers and you know it was very
interesting to learn and just almost
inspiring to learn how much power
intermediaries have in determining the
kinds of information that you get at the
same time you could see over the course
I started in 2007 over the course of the
time that I was working there how the
changes in the way that people were
getting information was really impacting
the news media and as we know the news
media is one of the fundamental parts of
functioning democracies and so we start
to worry as well about whether we're
going to always be able to have the same
kinds of investigative journalism that
we've had in the past so you know the
the big stylized facts are that the
media the news media is under a lot of
pressure there's a fallen advertising
revenue classify it's got unbundled web
avenues ad revenue is low and then we've
heard lessee newsrooms getting cut
journalists getting fired local
newspapers going bankrupt and so on and
the rise of a lot of new forms of ways
for people to get information and I
think
in this election season it's sort of
particularly salient when when it's been
widely observed that perhaps the the
changes in the way the news media works
and the changes in the way people get
their messages out may have affected you
know the way that the discussion has has
occurred and the success of candidates
so this is sort of the chart of doom for
the news media
this shows a newspaper ad revenue
normalized in nineteen eighty dollars
and sort of shows is you know the as the
Internet becomes important the newspaper
ad revenue sort of falling off a cliff
and so you know this is just a really
highlight they I mean we should be
concerned about the future in some sense
you know then the news media the fact
that it was so profitable for a period
of time is perhaps what we should think
about as kind of an accident of history
and technology the newspaper newspapers
are creating information goods it's
fairly easy to copy information goods
it's actually it would be kind of hard
to protect your intellectual property
and in the context of news we have to
have constitutional protections freedom
of speech that make it hard to keep
people from copying news and there was
this this kind of moment in time where
the news was delivered as a newspaper
that bundled together lots of things and
you had sort of a little local monopoly
over over local advertisers and could be
quite profitable and so in some sense
we're gonna be may look back and say
that was a very interesting and unique
moment in time where there was a
profitable business model for news and
the rest of the time that comes after
where it's much harder for that to be
profitable maybe more of the normal
state of affairs so what I'm going to
talk about today is I'm going to start
with a theory paper that I wrote that
tried to sort of think about how the
changes and how people consume
information affects advertising markets
and advertising revenue and then I'm
going to move into empirical work that
tries to uncover empirical facts about
how changes in how people get their news
affect what news people read and what
news outlets are advantaged
to start let me talk about the theory
and we're really gonna focus in on
consumer switching so we want to think
about two facts um the internet makes it
much easier for consumers to switch
between outlets they've sort of changed
your loyalty so you used to read one
newspaper and now you read many and so
that's not surprising that that might
change the way that markets work the
second that fact is that it's actually
hard to keep track of which consumers
have seen which ads across different
news outlets so just as a little bit of
fact around that course some people have
the feeling that what happens online is
like perfect and other people have the
stereotype that it's horrible so the
truth is actually sort of somewhere in
the middle so there are lots of cookies
out there that track your behavior and
try to keep track of where you've gone
and what ads you've seen but they only
work sort of medium well so this is a
little chart showing data from an
analysis for a company called comScore
and comScore has a panel of a couple
hundred thousand users that they and
they track for those users everything
that they do online and so what they
looked at was 30 large advertising
campaigns done by large national
advertisers that had attempted to reach
every consumer between three and eight
times and they could use state of the
art you know technology to try to
achieve that goal including use of
cookies and so on but what they found
after they did the very best they could
to reach users between three and eight
times is that actually half of their
impressions either
we're either given to users that saw one
or two ads early users that saw more
than eight ads and although this may
seem kind of arbitrary the industry
believes that those are sort of wasted
ad impressions so this is just to
indicate that it's actually pretty hard
when consumers are switching from outlet
to outlet to sort of keep track of what
what ads they saw so if I think about
now trying to bring those facts into
media economics so I should say
traditional media economics is
relatively new economists have only
really been building models of how
advertising markets work for like 15 or
20 years this is relatively new research
it's a theory the general theory is a
theory of two-sided markets and so in
this kind of these models are kind of
going to formalize the idea you might
have thought of what a newspaper does is
it creates news but a newspapers
business is the business of matching
users to advertisers they create content
to try to get people to come and read
them so they have a brand a user brand
awareness around news but their business
is matching users and advertisers and so
that this sort of the traditional media
economics model written by Anderson
encode has the idea that people are
going to single home that is go to only
one media outlet at the time so a user
might go to either the Boston Globe or
the New York Times but they're generally
not going to go to both at the same time
and then the the media outlet is is like
the platform that's connecting the two
sides of the market they're gonna bring
sell advertising to the users and
typically the advertisers if their
national advertiser would multi-home
that is they would advertise on both the
Boston Globe and the Washington Post
when they do that they're gonna reach a
completely disjoint set of users and so
the the newspapers in some sense will
have the we call it a competitive
bottleneck they're going to have access
to a set of users and so once they
attract the users they're eight
basically able to auction them off to
the advertisers and essentially charge
monopoly prices so the theory of how
this works is that you compete hard you
hire lots of reporters to get users but
once you have your users you have a
monopoly over those users and the only
way to get them if you're trying to do
the kind of advertising that goes
through newspapers is to go through the
only way to get Boston users is to go
through the Boston Globe and so as a
result any trust policy around
newspapers you know as recently as like
twenty years ago was all about those
evil newspapers charging monopoly prices
to their local advertisers and there was
policy around preventing newspaper
mergers because which would allow the
newspapers to exercise their already
extensive market power over the local
advertisers so newspapers were a
monopoly problem and they were too
profitable very very recently so you
know that's the old world the new world
is going to try to get it the fact that
now people are because of technological
changes able to switch between outlets
so instead of going to one newspaper
outlet or another they're going to go to
multiple outlets but it's not it's also
not going to be the case that they're
definitely going to go to all outlets
they're going to be sort of
stochastically switching across outlets
so it's gonna be sort of an environment
of partial multihoming and that's
something that again hadn't been this
whole theory is relatively recent but
that those hits are partially
multihoming assumptions hadn't been very
well developed now our question is going
to be well once you move to this and or
world what's that going to do to what
the advertisers do because now the
advertisers might reach the same users
on multiple outlets so the in some sense
there's more than one way to reach a
given user and furthermore they're gonna
have to worry about hitting the same
users twice across multiple outlets so
the question is what will advertisers do
I don't want to assume that advertisers
go to multiple outlets it made sense for
them to go to multiple outlets if there
was a completely disjoint set of users
in New York and Washington but they may
not choose to do so anymore and then
what's gonna happen to the money so
thinking about this from an advertisers
perspective you can say okay there's a
user might come along they come to
outlet one and in the morning you can
show them a Starbucks ad now they might
come back to the same outlet in the
afternoon maybe they read a different
page and so they read a different app
they might see a different out a Zipcar
ad and we can assume that by showing
different ads on different pages or
using cookie tracking that was in an
outlet you can you can sort of make sure
that users don't see the same ad twice
but if but that user might not come to
two two outlet one in the afternoon they
might also go to outlet two and if
things work well maybe they'll see a
different advertisement on outlet two on
the other hand they might get unlucky
and see the same ad again which is
inefficient from the perspective of the
advertisers and so from the perspective
of the advertiser if they single home
that is that they go to only one outlet
they might miss some people but if they
multi home and go to two different
outlets they might hit the same person
twice and that's gonna create some
inefficiency so what we what we try to
explore the paper we build a theoretical
model is well what are the implications
of all of this for how advertising
prices work and also for the incentives
of news outlets so how are the changes
in the world going to change the kinds
of strategies outlets will follow and so
what we basically show is that well if
you could perfectly track users across
outlets this competition the fact that
you can see the same user in multiple
outlets is going to lower advertising
prices it's gonna be a standard kind of
competition effect but if you add an
imperfect tracking the fact that you
might hit the same advertiser that see
the advertiser might hit the same user
twice we're going to get more complex
effects and in particular we're going to
see advertisers choosing not to
advertise on all outlets so you get this
interesting equilibrium where high value
advertisers are going to advertise on
all outlets so at a certain price the
high value advertisers are going to say
I realize when I advertise on all
outlets
I'm not getting one user per ad I'm
getting less than one user per ad
because I'm gonna duplicate some people
so one ad is equal to a fraction of a
user but I like users so much that even
getting only a fraction of a user per ad
I'm willing to pay for it if I'm a a
lower value advertiser
I say oh gosh if I'm only getting a
fraction of user per ad that's too
expensive for me but if I focus on a
smaller number of outlets then I'm gonna
still get one user per ad and so then
that price
is is less than my value and I can
afford to advertise so I can afford to
advertise on a small number of outlets
when I make sure I don't have any waste
but if I tried to advertise on lots of
outlets there would be so much waste
that it wouldn't be worthwhile for me
and so we see this this mixed homing
which reduces the demand for advertising
which reduces advertising prices further
beyond the competitive effect and so
generally the more switching people do
the bigger this inefficiency is and the
more advertising demand is reduced so
the high-level comparative static is all
this consumer switching the fact that
you've become disloyal is really going
to hurt advertising prices in
advertising markets and we can also
think about then what seconded what's
going to happen in the world of media
competition so things like blogs that
don't have a lot of advertising we can
think about what those do those take up
time but they don't add advertising
capacity to the market and so they might
actually be bad if the blog steals your
readers but good for advertising prices
because they take up time and without
taking up advertising space so they kind
of reduce the ply aggregators are going
to increase switching so things I'm
going to show you some facts about that
later so Google News or Huffington Post
might distribute you across a lot of
different outlets that increase
switching is going to be bad for
advertising prices and then we can think
about media strategy like if you put up
a paywall and you reduce your audience
okay if you put up the paywall and
reduce your audience then small
advertisers if they have to pick just
one outlet they want to pick a big
outlet so they can get as a lot of
consumers they don't want to pick a
small outlet where they don't get as
many consumers so smaller outlets become
disadvantaged in the advertising
marketplace so by putting up a paywall
you first lose a bunch of your users and
then you second get lower price per user
because you're smaller the smaller you
are the lower your price per user on the
other hand something like facebook which
sees many many users maybe not all day
not exclusively but they see all users
once they have a really advantage
because
in the advertising market because they
can sell to an advertiser the chance to
reach everybody once without any
duplication and in fact that is what
Facebook sells their advertisers they
don't sell Network information or they
sell basically reach the ability to
reach so in all of that context we then
it might expect to see a lot of media
mergers consolidation and a lot of
benefits to being big and broad which
you know will change the kinds of news
that we get alright so then now let me
move on to talk more detail and show
some more empirical work about the power
of aggregators and intermediaries and
now I'm going to move away from
advertising markets effects and focus on
what happens to consumers and the kinds
of news that they read so first I just
want to highlight a specific finding
this is the one slide that overlaps with
my talk from earlier today I want to
talk about the power of intermediaries
to change what you read so when I worked
in a search engine this is completely
obvious if you work in any online firm
it's obvious but if you're not in
Silicon Valley you might actually think
that you choose what you read okay you
might think that you control your own
destiny um and it just turns out that
your your role in choosing what you do
is much smaller than you think it is you
are much more influenced by
intermediaries that the the
intermediaries are kind of puppeteers
and you're all the puppets so how do you
kind of document the magnitude of that
well I when I was doing some work with
Microsoft for the European Commission
and the the chief economist office said
well you know we we think that the we
under we found some documents we've
we've got internal documents from Google
that shows that Google has manipulated
their search results to put Google on
top and put other things smaller so we
know that they put Google Finance on top
even though Yahoo is better we have
evidence that says that they did this
but really what difference could it make
as an economist I'm used to thinking
about search Kostis be like driving to
another store not standing your eyeballs
three inches
Paige right from a policy perspective
how big a deal could it be to scan your
eyeballs three inches so in response to
this question I ran a randomized
controlled experiment at being with a
couple million users and just before the
users were about to see their search
results we reversed the ranking of the
results so we took what was supposed to
go on position one and ran was it in
position three took what was position
three and put it in position one and
then we saw how does that affect how
many clicks the users do so up here the
control users for the control treatment
when the thing that's supposed to be on
top is in the first position it's
clicked 25% of the time but when you
take that thing in position one and move
it down to position three they lose 13.5
percent of clicks that is their new
click-through rate is only 12 percent
instead of 25% so just moving the result
from position 1 to position 3 makes you
lose more than half of your clicks and
this also holds up if you look at what
you know dwell time or other measures
the difference between the light bar in
the dark bar is showing the difference
between is essentially separating
correlation from causality so in the in
the baseline data the thing that was
normally in position 3 was clicked 7
percent of the time but when I take the
thing from position 1 and put it into
position 3 it's clicked 12 percent of
the time and so that's showing the thing
that was in position 1 was better than
the thing that was in position 3 that is
being our idiots they put better things
on top but if you take the good thing
and you move it down the page it's gonna
lose more than half of its place and of
course if you move it to the bottom the
page it loses most of its clicks so of
course I'm gonna be talking about other
things than search today but I was able
to run a randomized experiment here and
not in on Google News so I just but just
the point is that the way that news is
organized the way that information is
presented can make a very big difference
on what you read and how inform the
population is and therefore whether or
not they believe you know facts that
aren't facts
I had an anecdote from a from a US
legislature who said that you know 10-15
years ago maybe you know you get these
letters from the constants
and only you know a small share were
about non facts you know oh I have this
big problem X is happening but X isn't
happening is it today you know like some
Lord share of the questions that come in
from constituents involve non facts so
I'm so worried because you know the
Affordable Care Act is gonna make me do
X but the affirmative Care Act is not
going to make me do X ok so if you think
about the role of these of the
information that we get on the internet
and misinformation we might think these
things are important whether or not
people are getting their news ranked by
Facebook ranked by aggregators and so on
so now I'm gonna talk about aggregators
so aggregators things like Google News
and so on that get in between the user
and the newspapers and then after I talk
about aggregators also touch on social
media things like Facebook and Twitter
so the first the first study is was
really I got started on it and it's I've
been working on this for embarrassingly
long time in 2009 I I was I spoke at a
workshop at the FTC where a bunch of
newspapers had come together to ask the
FTC to get sorts of antitrust exemption
to help them band together and fight
against the evil aggregators so they
were very upset with Google News and
other intermediaries that they felt were
sort of stealing their content so Google
News presents a page that looks a lot
like the New York Times home page except
Google News doesn't actually hire any
reporters they're going to show snippets
from other newspapers it looks like the
New York Times page and so the New York
Times might feel that that's a
substitute for them it's a competitor
but yet they're not they're not actually
having to bear any of the costs of
producing the journalism so also on the
stage much more interesting than
anything I said we're both Rupert
Murdoch and Arianna Huffington um so
this made a very amusing conference so
Arianna Huffington had gone through all
of Rupert Murdoch's speeches and found
some choice quotes so Arianna Huffington
quoting
Rupert Murdoch Rupert Murdoch says that
Google News is our parasites content
kleptomaniacs vampires tech tapeworms on
the intestines of the internet and
thieves who steal all our copyright so
let's pause on the tech tapeworms one
that's really fun isn't it um I actually
love that because whatever you think of
Rupert Murdoch he's actually a really
good economist he's a good business
person and a good economist so he's
actually using a very nice metaphor for
the economics because what he's saying
is that a parasite well they don't do
any of their own work so the the
newspapers go out and do all the work
and send the reporters to Syria and risk
their lives Google News doesn't do any
of that and there's and and but the
parasite kind of sucks the life out of
their hosts so people are going to
Google News and not seeing any
advertising rather than going to the New
York Times and seeing advertising
therefore they're stealing advertising
revenue they're taking away the returns
to the investment from the New York
Times
so then Rupert Murdoch goes on to say I
mean now him speaking in his own words
to paraphrase a famous economist there's
no such thing as a free news story that
is hey Rupert Murdoch's not in the
charity business
he's only finding reporters to Syria
because he expects to get a return on
his investment and if they read that
news on Google News he's not getting the
return on the investment therefore the
person who did the R&D is not rewarded
on the other hand Arianna Huffington
says you're not in toto anymore I mean
on Kansas anymore toto the world has
changed and she says aggregators are
like taxis they drive traffic to
newspapers and they lower the cost of
news discovery so what I'm gonna do is
try to provide evidence to sort these
things out is it the case that Google
News helps you find stuff or is it the
case that it steals readers from
newspapers okay and of course both could
be going on and indeed that is what
we're gonna find so if we think about
how we could possibly tease this out
though it's a little bit difficult
because after all so at the FTC
conference a guy from Google says
oh gosh to newspapers if you don't like
us you can opt out of Google News it's
okay just tell us you don't want us to
be there and we'll take you out but
that's a little bit disingenuous because
if you take out one newspaper that
doesn't affect the Google News at all so
it doesn't affect user behavior but that
one newspaper is going to lose traffic
and that traffic is going to go to
someone else so an experiment where one
newspaper left Google News wouldn't
really tell us much about the overall
impact of Google News so what we need to
try to study this empirically is we
would like to see a world with Google
News in a world without Google News or
maybe we would like to see a world with
Google News with all of its content and
a world with with Google News with some
big block of content gone so I'm going
to show two natural experiments that
occurred where I can approximate those
kinds of counterfactuals and so
therefore measure the impact so the
first one is Spain and so just like at
the FTC newspapers all over the world
have been going to their of governments
and legislatures to complain about how
these intermediaries are kind of
stealing their stuff and not sharing
revenue so in Spain the Parliament
actually listened to the newspapers and
they passed the law saying Google News
would have to share revenue with the
newspaper publishers the next day Google
News shut down in Spain so that provided
us with this interesting natural
experiment to see what happened when
Google News goes away so we're gonna try
to measure the effects of this by you
looking looking at a sample of internet
browsing data now say all of my
empirical work is is based on PC
browsing data this is very sad because
especially social media mostly goes on
mobile I don't have that data I wish I
did so I do the best I can with with
what I've got
so I'm gonna get a sample of 160,000 PC
Internet users in Spain who read at
least one news website per week during
the relevant time period I'm gonna look
at 175 Spanish news outlets that
together comprise 95% of news browsing
and I'm going to
basically try to use my data to
understand what the impact of Google
News shutting down was so in the weeks
after Google news shut down it was
reported in the newspapers in Spain
because they were all very interested in
this the shutting down Google News had
been a disaster for Spanish news outlets
news browsing in Spain was down 10 15 20
percent week over week but if you look
at the dates down here a little bit
you'll notice something on this is
Christmas
and so news browsing in the weeks
leading up to Christmas was sort of on a
on a steady decline there was also this
crazy spike here where the princess was
indicted on corruption charges
so we're so we might worry right away
that trying to just look at what
happened before and after might be a
little bit difficult because of holidays
and other special events it might be
difficult to say that well what would
have happened afterwards if it hadn't
been for the Spanish News was this this
this chart would have just extended
without any fluctuations so I want I
need to do something else and then when
you look into the data a little bit more
carefully you start to get very
suspicious about the idea that Google
News could have caused a 20% decline in
news consumption because actually the so
here this is actually it turns out that
Google News is only a very small share
of news referrals so what I've got on
this chart are different forms of
referral sources referral sources what
sends you to a newspaper direct
navigation is when you go directly to
New York Times com search is when you
search a topic on Google search and then
you click on a link and go to the story
Google News is when you go to
news.google.com and you look at the
thing that looks like a news outlets
homepage and that's actually very small
in Spain it's important worldwide but in
Spain it's not super popular so Google
search was really important but Google
News itself was not all that important
and that's the only thing that shut down
so clearly losing you know a tiny
fraction of people couldn't have caused
a major change all across the board now
after I did this this chart you might
have thought maybe I should just quit my
research project because this is sort of
too small to study but what I did
instead
as I said well alright obviously I can't
study the effect of Google News shutting
down on people who don't use Google News
but what I can do is study the effect of
Google News shutting down on the people
who do use Google News and what I'm
going to do instead is I'm going to
construct myself a synthetic control
group a set of people that look like my
Google News people except they don't use
Google News and I'm going to use them to
construct a counterfactual time trend of
what would have happened if Google News
had stayed had stayed in business so
just to kind of show you the picture on
Google News versus Google search Google
get his homepage and it's a little bit
hard to see in a small screenshot but
it's something that has all the
different categories of news and it's
going to be organized by topic and this
is going to be affected by the law when
you go to google.com and search for say
Joe Biden you're gonna get search
results they look similar but this is
this is this is kind of do regular
Google search and that's where most of
the news referrals come from people just
type into their browser what they're
looking for and they get a Google search
result okay so what my empirical
strategy again is going to be that what
I want to do is construct the
counterfactual time trend I want to know
counterfactually if Google News had not
shut down what would my Google News
user's have done in the successive
periods and so to construct the
synthetic control group what I do is I
take people in the period before check
down that looked just like my Google
News users in terms of how much news
they read as well as how much they use
the Internet okay and I'm gonna do
there's many ways you could do this I'm
going to keep things simple I'm gonna do
exact matching I've got 20 buckets of
news consumption and 20 buckets of
internet usage and I'm gonna match my
people exactly with other people in that
bucket and so you can see in the pre
period my matching I haven't matched
this day by day I just matched this on
aggregate but I did a pretty good job
with my matching because the time trends
daily
weekdays weekends etc mash up really
nicely in the pre period but once we get
to the post period they diverge and so
what happens is that the Google News
users in red the people I'm gonna call
these my treatment users the people that
were affected by the shutdown reduce
their news relative to the
counterfactual time trend so of course
we see you can see directly that they
reduce their their news overall but what
the blue line helps me do is to say well
gosh there would have been a spike on
this christen princess Christina day and
indeed there is and it also helps me say
that well after Christmas the news the
news reading should have popped back up
but it didn't okay so using this
approach which economists call
difference in different strategy it's a
very simple empirical strategy I can
estimate a fifteen point six percentage
reduction in news pageviews and a
seventeen point five percent reduction
in articles so the pageviews include the
landing pages the front pages as well as
the articles themselves and so I'm in a
distinguish among those so that's my
baseline finding that if you take Google
News away from people they're gonna read
less news and so that supports the
Google News perspective that Google News
is a complement to news outlets but then
so that's a the question was is it a
substitute or a complement and let me
just pause for a second and say that
this type of question about a new
business model is something that comes
up in a lot of new internet businesses
so is uber a substitute for taxis is
uber a substitute for black cars or is
it something else is Airbnb a substitute
for hotels you know in in some sense you
know for vacation renters maybe Airbnb
is a complement for for smaller vacation
rental people who could list through
Airbnb so Airbnb is a complement for
some things and it's a substitute for
other things and so it's pretty common
that these new internet businesses
our heart it's hard to put them in a
market it's hard to say
are they competitors or compliments for
the existing markets and often they're a
little bit of both depending on who you
look at Airbnb is not really a
substitute for a fancy hotel but it
might be a Santa substitute for a
low-end hotel and so on so that way we
can now I'm going to show you I'm not
going to do the all these full pictures
anymore but I'm going to show you
summary statistics which are called the
different gifs estimates and so the
different dip estimates you can think of
is it's the difference it's this blue -
red - blue - red and so generally blue -
red that difference is going to be very
small in the pre period and it's going
to be bigger in the post period it's
that difference in difference is my
estimate of the causal effect of Google
News okay so I can break things out
first of all in terms of what kinds of
content are affected in which way by
Google News going away and in particular
have been breaking out articles landing
pages landing pages exclude in Google
News because Google News is itself like
a homepage and other content and so I'm
going to see that when you take Google
News away you're going to read less
articles but you're actually going to go
read more landing pages so the home
pages of newspapers are going to benefit
from Google News going away but you're
so like that from the New York Times
perspective you would see they're gonna
come to my home page more but I read my
articles less okay so that's a sort of a
mixed effect and of course the home
pages are where they make a lot of their
advertising revenue that's where the
most expensive ads aren't getting back
to my previous point advertisers like to
get a lot of reach and so advertising on
that home page is a way to get a lot of
users and not hit too many of them twice
so then we can say we'll look a little
more closely at how people redistributed
their reading if Google News goes away
what do they do next and so they they
substitute a lot to direct referrals and
to search so they say searches a little
bit of a substitute for Google News
when you when you take it away
and then I could also look at how long
people spend and all of our results are
kind of robust to looking at how long
people spend one thing you might worry
about is when you go to Google News you
click on lots of things but you don't
stay there very long and that's true to
some extent but it's only a small effect
so roughly the effects on pageviews are
the same as the results on dwell time
but now let's start to get a little bit
more interesting so I've said so far
Google News overall is a compliment for
the news industry but actually the
effects are gonna be quite heterogeneous
so I can first of all break out the news
outlets into top-5 outlets middle 15 and
less than 20 and so it's gonna turn out
is it when Google News goes away the top
five outlets are helped so Google News
is a competitor for the top five if you
think about that intuitively you know
that if you don't have Google News what
are you gonna do you're gonna find
another top outlet and go there to get
your overall coverage now from that
perspective if you think that also the
top five outlets are the ones sending
reporters to Syria and doing a lot of
the in-depth investigative journalism
then you start to feel a little bit less
sanguine about this because you guys say
gosh like Google News really is a
substitute for the New York Times and
therefore its existence might be funding
less reporters to Syria and less
publication for the middle six to twenty
it's kind of a wash overall and for the
book for the small outlets taking Google
News away is bad so Google lose hope
small outlets again if you think about
it how often do you actually type in the
URL for a small outlet generally you're
getting sent there by somebody else and
the search costs of kind of trying to go
there and look are just too high to make
it worth your time so for small outlets
Google News is a search engine it helps
you find stuff and even though in
general it's not worth your time to go
to these small outlets occasionally they
have a really good story or they're the
first to break the story if they do
Google News is gonna reward you and send
you there so in the in then
in the policy space actually there's a
lot of people in the journalism
scholarship area that worry a lot about
media diversity and so those people find
say uh this is really exciting Google
News is really good because it helps you
find lots of small outlets and helps us
provide diversity so something that
would take more work and I've been
working on this for years so I haven't
dug into this yet that I could possibly
try to do is really measure the
diversity of the news and figure out
whether Google News increases or
decreases diversity and I haven't done
that yet but I am gonna show you a few
results that are suggestive in that
direction so bottom line is that I can
say who's heard and who's helped but I
don't know what the implications are for
welfare but generally we would like
people to be visiting the sites that do
the R&D and so whichever R&D is
non-duplicate 'iv and unique and
valuable those are the people where we'd
like the consumers to be reading their
news because that's that's gonna be what
funds that research week but we just
don't know where we really want more
users to go okay so we also can look at
switching so number of distinct outlets
visit it and of course it's kind of
pretty intuitive but when you take
Google News away you give pretty large
reductions in the number of distinct
outlets visited across all outlets but
especially for small outlets so your
Google news and things like Google News
make you much less loyal as a reader
that can have implications for
advertising revenue as well because if
the newspaper doesn't know the reader
they can't serve them as relevant ads
and they also won't make as much money
on them so now let's let's think go a
little bit deeper into like what is
actually special about Google News and
other online intermediaries so one thing
is that it allows you to read more
deeply on preferred topics and do more
research as a user second and this is
something newspapers get upset about and
sort of got this unfair advantage from a
newspapers perspective but a very
convenient advantage from a user's
perspective of having the latest news if
any news outlet has broken a story
Google News can have it five seconds
later
and if it's an interesting story and if
people start searching for it on Google
com they can put it at the top of their
page and they will then they will be be
able to get that story first so let me
just show I'm gonna get to looking at
the the ability what so I'm gonna try to
break out what kinds of news are very
hard for for users to find substitutes
for when Google News goes away so we
break out news according to how recent
the news is in the first hour send
publication up to 11 plus and we also
break out news into news that is scarce
and non scarce for a particular user so
if you usually read the New York Times I
look at my control users and I see does
New York Times cover this topic more or
less than the news news industry as a
whole and so I for every user I find
their most popular outlets and then I
determine for that user whether a topic
is under covered on their preferred
outlets or not and then what I do is I
try to estimate whether users whether
the Google News users are going to be
able to find a good substitute for their
news reading according to how scarce it
is as well as according to how recent it
is so what I do is I make a prediction
and the prediction are the long bars
about how much the goat the Google News
users news readings should be reduced if
I just zeroed out the Google news from
their browsing and didn't replace it
with anything so this is like the
counterfactual if Google News goes away
and they don't substitute so for example
my prediction here is that for very
recent very scarce news you would see
about if you just zeroed out Google News
they would see like a seventeen seventy
seven percent reduction in reading that
kind of news if you took Google News
away then the dark bar is the actual and
so in this case the the counterfactual
equals the actual that is if you took
Google News
you would lose 77% and and in fact they
do lose 77% they cannot find a good
substitute for that so they just lose
very recent news that is not well
covered on their preferred um news
outlets on the other hand way up here
for non scarce news that is that has
been broken for more than half a day I
would predict if you just zeroed out
Google News you would get more than a 20
percent reduction in that news reading
but actually they only get like a 7
percent reduction which is basically
saying that they were able to find good
substitutes for stuff that's well
covered on their own outlets and that's
not very recent
so essentially what Google we might try
to account for what kind of news is
going away your Google News users are
losing their access to to news that was
covered on a wider range of outlets and
they usually read and to news that was
recently breaking and so I think what I
think about the strategy of the news
industry therefore this is kind of what
you're competing with if you're trying
to keep from losing your users what your
users are getting elsewhere that they're
not getting on the New York Times is
this kind of recent news and also in
depth coverage which leads me to the
same conclusion I had for my advertising
thing which is I would expect to see
more mergers more joint ventures more
sharing of content as well as sharing of
user data by a larger set of outlets
consolidation that'll be good for the
economics good for keeping users perhaps
not so good for media diversity so just
in my last couple minutes I had we did
another study in France um where we got
similar results let me talk very briefly
about the impact of Facebook on news
consumption and so we have a similar
kind of data set but in what we do for
this study is that we put the news
articles into topics things like Boston
Marathon bombing 2013 war tornado and we
using text mining techniques and then
once we've got them into topics were
then able to use crowdsourcing to
understand what are the characteristics
of different topics as well as what are
the
characteristics of different articles
and so we use a we use a grass technique
to do the topic modeling i'm aided by
wikipedia and so just to give like a few
of the findings that we have first of
all you might have thought that not what
i'm going to be comparing is what you
read when you go directly to a news
outlet versus what do you read when you
get go from facebook or twitter so the
blue is what you do with social media
the red is what you do when you go
directly and the green is counted
adjusting for user mix so it's trying to
adjust for the fact that the you
different users use social media and
direct navigation so if the green and
the blue are close together that
basically says that adjusting for user
mix there's not much difference with
social media and direct navigation so we
find at the very high level there
actually aren't a lot of differences
between the high level topics crime
celebrity business between social media
and direct navigation but we do find a
lot more within topic variation for
example we find that on social media
people read stories that are written
differently stories that have an
individual perspective stories that
assume background knowledge we find a
stories that do in-depth analysis
controversial opinion politically
controversial as well as those with a
caring supporting attitude are all more
prevalent on social media we we find as
well that there's more specific
targeting like there's more articles
shared targeted towards women or
families on social media then there is
when you go from direct navigation and
we find some differences in positivity
and compassion as well between direct
navigation and social media so what we
see is that what brought the high level
topics aren't different but the way the
articles are written and how they're
told and researched is different so the
final thing that we look at is political
bias and and these numbers actually
we've done a pilot study and we're
trying to do a longer study because
these numbers are probably the most
sensitive
the sample size we first of all look at
and find that when we look out at topics
some topics tend very conservative and
some tend very liberal so if you're
gonna read an article about school
shootings it tends to skew very liberal
if you're gonna read an article about
Benghazi they tend to skew very
conservative and in fact one of the big
determinants if you want to try to
predict the political bias of an article
the topic can be more important than the
news outlet and predicting those things
so the big difference between the Fox
and New York Times is that Fox covers
Benghazi if there's ever a story about
Benghazi they're going to cover it if
you ask they're digital people they'll
say that's intentional that's their
strategy that's what one of the big
things that's different between news
outlets then what we do we take
advantage of our of our topic
classifications to crowdsource the
political bias of articles only for
articles that are potentially
politically biased so we throw out the
articles about tornadoes and about
sports events and only study articles
that are that are potentially
politically biased and then we look at
whether people read more biased stuff
off of social media and again these
exact numbers are probably a little bit
skewed because of my small simple but we
see that people read less neutral news
and more on on social media and more and
more neutral news on direct navigation
then what we do is we look at people who
we have we only look at a subset of
people who have read conservative
articles in the previous week and for
people that read a conservative article
in the previous week they do very little
liberal reading at all but they do do
some neutral reading from direct
navigation on contrast in social media
they're gonna skew very heavily
conservative and similarly for liberals
if you've read a liberal article in the
last week we find that you're gonna read
very little conservative stuff overall
but again you'll get some neutral
content when you go directly to a news
homepage but but not so much on on in
terms of social media and so in a sense
we can think however bias do you think
the
our times is however bias do you think
fox news's there's still less biased
than your friends and what your friends
share with you and so you know there
there's gonna be some very factual
reporting coming from major news outlets
and as a result I think we should be a
little bit concerned about the changes
and how people get their news as they
start going more and more through social
media and they're not sure aided by kind
of editors who at least are trying to be
objective some of the time
but rather are getting curated by your
friends you may become less well
informed and and write your Congressman
about non facts and vote for candidates
on the basis of misinformation so
broadly it's a it's a kind of a mixed
bag but you know we whatever is going on
we are seeing some pretty big impacts
and I expect that the media industry is
going to go through some pretty major
changes and so we're gonna have to think
as a society how we fund it as well as
how we protect the informativeness of
our population in this new digital age
on the other hand the good news is that
finding stuff for people does seem to
make them read and so if we can find
good ways to present accurate
information to people in a convenient
way convenient timely way maybe in fact
we can get people to read so that's it
thank you very much
so happy to take questions and I learned
that from the Pittsburgh post-gazette
supposedly in the United States there
are 3,500 journalists but 40,000 company
public relations officers and when they
wanted to publish an article in the
Pittsburgh post-gazette
about all kinds of health challenges
from nuclear and coal fired power plants
and so on they were talking to companies
who then immediately told their public
relations officer and then the public
relations officer contacted they let's
say lawyers and they immediately called
the editors of the paper if you publish
this paper we will sue you so when you
think about this that we have only three
and a half thousand journalists and
40,000 public relations officers and how
that relates to educate the public about
important issues that are connected what
would your recommendation be that you
could study in yours well that's a
pretty deep question I mean and the
question really concern is the role of
businesses influencing the press and I
have to say that that's among the many
things I learned in my time with
industry was that that goes on much more
than you ever would have thought and
there there can be sort of you know quid
pro quos between you know companies
trying to give journalists information
so they can get a story out and then the
journalists kind of covering it more
favorably at least the companies would
hope that would happen and so sometimes
you might see a story and say oh gosh it
looks like that company planted it and
so on and I think there that does
absolutely go on what you would hope is
that the companies the companies kind of
bottle it out and so if they have
opposing interests both sides get aired
and the competitive process lets the
information come out I think the problem
is that it may be it's something like
you say where most of the companies
interests lie in one direction and
they're able to invest in research and
persuasive information and maybe they
believe it's very maybe they believe
what they're they're saying and maybe
their research supports it but it's just
one perspective and then there's nobody
investing the corresponding offsetting
R&D on the other side and absolutely I
think those are things that we should be
very worried about um I think in this
country in the current political
environment it's highly unlikely we're
going to do more public funding of
journalism so it's a problem on a debate
where the question was to search engines
actually cause more kind of
specialization let's say on conservative
versus liberal or do they allow you to
carve more niches and are we getting it
kind of more focused with search engines
or less focused and have you thought
about the role that search engines could
play basically or or news or news things
like Google News trying to tell people
at ok hey I've been watching your news
reading patterns and you're really been
reading only liberal stuff so let me
recommend some things for you here so
you can a less biased view well I think
this is a really interesting question
and I mean you know I think the first
round of so when I first started lying
to study this actually like oh nine and
ten it turned out that actually the
level of personalization happening in
news just across the board was pretty
low so there was really nothing large to
study I mean it was happening but it was
just he was getting personalization
signals we're getting swamped by all the
other signals now I think it's growing
pretty substantially and you know the
naive algorithms are just going to try
to find publication of facts and so on
they're gonna say oh this this user
likes these kinds of publications so I'm
going to show them more publications
like that so they would create this
filter bubble and Facebook's algorithm
same thing they're not gonna show me
stuff I'm not gonna click on right and
sure they can observe this stuff and so
they're absolutely going to rank on it
there's a deeper question we actually
talking about this at lunch whether in
some sense this is where like the social
scientists could
and say gosh you know I know in the
short-term like this is the thing that's
gonna maximize whole page click-through
was to show you more of what you like
but maybe in the long term you're gonna
value this diverse perspective maybe
you're forming a perception about
neutrality and so on but it would be
very hard to measure that and so
tomorrow I'm going to talk about the
difficulty of short-termism in a
data-driven world but if you had a kind
of visionary person and you could
convince yourself somehow that this was
a true factor maybe some publications
could differentiate themselves by making
sure to provide a balanced perspective
but my fear is because it's so hard to
measure those long-term effects even if
someone had the idea in a data-driven
world they would get crushed because you
couldn't actually demonstrate might take
two years of watching a user before you
really get the benefits of showing that
diverse perspective and so you wouldn't
be able to document it even if it was
really there it's so much easier to
measure clicks yeah and I mean maybe
they could allow you to express that
that preference but I think they're
probably worried about seeming creepy
you know like in some sense if you
realize if you tell people that that's
an option you know they might worry
about it so I think these are very
subtle subtle issues but I would not
predict that in the short-term you're
gonna see a lot of that I think it'll be
a longer time before we get and good
enough at measurement and people get
sophisticated enough that companies are
comfortable giving you those kinds of
choices then you can just clear your
cookies in yep slice oh very interesting
and I'm wondering if you can the slice
can tell us something about like for
example the liberals and conservatives
they differ in their opinion because
they have different preferences or
because they are preconditioned with
different information for example here
you both sides are really neutral
neutral news news media's but
at the end of the day they recommend
actually send different information to
their friends yes so I think those are
incredibly interesting things and I
should have by the way I just wanted I
do want to give the caveat that these
numbers are probably a little bit skewed
by my small sample but what I would
really want to do I think is collaborate
with Facebook on an experiment like that
and and actually do some randomization
at the user level and also like
conditional on what their users were
sharing we're gonna rewrite it to really
understand that but I think that's a
kind of experiment would be a little bit
hard for Facebook to do and to publish
just because again I think it'd be kind
of sensitive to the users of the users
don't want their the political bias of
their news to be experimented on and
they might be angry if I published or
someone else publish such a paper but I
think the right data setting to do the
experiment you you would need to
collaborate with someone who could
actually change the rankings in order to
tease those things out this this
observational data I don't have any
randomization here I don't even have a
natural experiment so I'm just not able
to sort out why these things are
happening I think it's it's an it's kind
of instructive I mean I think it's a
suggestive that they do different things
on direct navigation and social media
but I can't say if it's because of what
they click on from what their friends
shared or whether it's what their
friends shared or whether it's
Facebook's ranking algorithm there's a
whole bunch of things that go into a big
soup on Facebook and and I'm without
more data I can't figure that out in
Facebook there are news articles that
are recommended by my actual friends and
they are often followed by a handful of
things that Facebook thinks I might also
like to look at I casually think that
there that that there's a better
distribution of bias in the things that
Facebook recommends but I haven't
actually tracked it very carefully does
your data separate that out and can you
say anything about the Facebook
recommends versus my actual friends
recommend phenomenon no I can't I mean
it's possible I could tease
from the URLs but it gets a little bit
tricky to figure out exactly where the
Facebook referrals come from just from
the data I have my observation is
similar to yours but I also think you
know I guess I haven't seen like in my
newsfeed I don't think I've seen a lot
of I don't think these books
recommending me a lot of pro Trump stuff
for example so it's probably figured out
that I don't want to read that yeah but
I but I do think in some sense that that
can substitute a little bit for the
direct navigation it's sort of the
curation of sort of high quality
articles but ultimately the Facebook's
is going to be looking at what its users
like right and that's that's gonna be
part of it
the brain of a person who's reading
something that that is contrary to their
opinion and they've they've they've seen
some proof of cognitive dissonance like
you don't really like reading something
that's not conversant with what you
would think so
given this background and flat how do
you think that we will be able to
incentivize people to read a more
balanced article because like as she
pointed out that Facebook actually now
does give recommendations based on
something that you clicked which which
places similar articles for you to click
on and even on Facebook when I see
people debating from opposite sides
usually no one agrees to the other
person it's like people take sides so
you end up finding like-minded people
and then you you can even unfollow
people who you know objected against you
in arguments well so man I think that's
part of what it's kind of sad that we're
losing so if you think about you know as
Facebook curates your news for you you
know you're not gonna go to the home
page of the newspaper and so you're
gonna be thinking instead of stories
that help create a balance front page of
a newspaper you're gonna be thinking
about stories that'll be ranked highly
on Facebook and get shared a lot and so
that's kind of an article level
optimization rather than a kind of paid
menu if you like or as Earths
huit of curated content and i think that
sort of suite of curated content that
makes a beautiful page was providing a
lot of the incentives for the newspapers
like they wanted they really cared about
what that page looked like and and what
perspectives it showed and that it
covered lots of different things they
really thought about that and when you
when you just find things article by
article you're you that's lost and I
think then the incentives for quality
reputation the incentives for balance
all of that goes away because I have no
idea anymore if the New York time is
balanced if I am only on Facebook right
because I'm only seeing the liberal
articles on Facebook and whatever they
wrote on conservative side I never even
see it so I have no idea if they're
balanced or not right and so that's I
think those are some of the things that
should concern us when you have these
new intermediaries coming on board so in
the short term by the way I should
really emphasize me what my results show
that Google News was good in the short
term but the long term you know when
when newspapers respond and outlets
change their strategy is is much more
ambiguous Susan first thank you very
much for a terrific presentation I'm
curious if you have any thoughts on the
implications of your research for the
business model of newspapers and online
media with is there any hope for online
advertising is there content based or or
paying subscription for content is there
a future do you have any thoughts on
this what's my teach a class on
two-sided markets and digital markets to
the MBAs and we have these night
journalism fellows who I'll take my
class every year and if the in spite
teach them about the role of the
platform and you know how you bring
together the different sides and you can
get the all these profits and one of the
journalism fellows at the end said Susan
I think what I learned the following
thing from your class my first example
was a farmers market so try to
illustrate that platforms aren't just
digital he said so basically what you're
saying is we used to be the farmers
market and now we're the farmers and
that's basically right Facebook is the
farmers market Google is the farmers
market that's the platform that's the
middleman that gets all the returns
the news organizations are
undifferentiated sellers of apples and
the farmers market is curating which
apples to do but but they're not going
to get much surplus so I think that is a
fundamental problem and the only real
answers I can see mean there's things
around the edges around different kinds
of advertising and subscription models
but ultimately I think that when because
the intermediaries are big it's their
size that really allows them all the
power the news media is gonna have to
get big in some way - which will give
them lots of economies of scale and data
and they'll have better machine learning
and they'll be faster and so on but on
the other hand we'll leave you know if
it's all owned by Rupert Murdoch you
know that's gonna give us a smaller
number of perspectives right so the call
to consolidation may go quite a ways and
it also might kill local and certain
kinds of things so it's a little
depressing okay